lithuanian foreign minister gabriele
lansberges is in the uk for talks with
his british counterparts tros and he's
taken the opportunity to join us hi it's
great to see you thanks for joining us
on the program this morning um what's
your country's assessment of the latest
situation in ukraine
well ukraine obviously has managed to
win a lot of battles
a battle for kiev
battle of harkif
already won
but it's clear that the war is not over
and therefore we have to make a very
clear commitment that we will continue
providing any assistance that is needed
by ukraine to win the war and
first and foremost on its terms so what
is the victory has to be defined by the
ukrainians themselves if they
manage to keep on winning and they
require the weapons from us this is what
we have to do
the fall of mario paul was a big blow
though
yes i would but i would say differently
that maripo
withstood for so long it's a miracle in
itself
that ukraine managed to win so many
battles is also a proof of
a spirit that ukrainian people have and
ukrainian warriors have so i think that
not every battle has to be won and i
think that uh mario will be retaken
how concerned are you about the
situation in odessa
i'm concerned because it's a part of uh
of a bigger issue uh that still is not
making uh so many headlines and i think
that
we will see more of that it's the
upcoming
food crisis
uh because russian blockade of odessa is
not allowing about 30 million tons of
wheat to leave the port and
the food is needed to to feed the
vulnerable countries in the world first
firstly in northern part of africa in
middle east and southeastern asia
and i think that the next step for
well for the responsible countries and
this is one of the subjects that we are
going to discuss today
with madame truss is how do we help to
unblock uh odessa if there's a chance to
do that at all or provide ukrainians
weapons that they could do that
themselves
in order to uh to open it up safely not
allowing russians in but allowing the
grain and corn to leave to leave to
leave odessa's sport and to reach the
countries that most needed
should there be sea-based support for
ukraine
uh i think so yes and uh what does that
look like
one of the things that
united kingdom already done you know the
some of the weaponry that was provided
to uh
to ukraine already helps to uh to shield
uh the port cities
uh but there's more that can be done
more advanced weaponry could be provided
obviously that takes time to
to adapt and to learn how to use it
but it's better if we start doing that
now
i'm not excluding the fact that there is
a chance to even to form a coalition of
the countries
maybe some of the nato countries maybe
some of the countries that need the
grain from from ukraine that could
provide
ships or planes that would be stationed
in in the black sea and provide a safe
maritime passage for the grain ships to
leave odessa sport and reach bosporus in
turkey and would there be warships
they could be yes
they could be yes
because there has to be a very that
would signify quite an escalation
well basically it would not signify an
escalation because it's not taking a
part in the war
it's just securing the grain passage
from ukraine to the countries that the
russians tried to stop that then what
would happen uh that is an excellent
point russians currently say that they
would not allow it but then we have to
admit the fact that then if we agree
with russians not allowing it so it's
not just again about the ukraine and the
war in ukraine but it's about that
russians are holding hostage
the
the vulnerable countries of the world
and not allowing ukrainians to feed them
so and and then it's this is a very
difficult question for us to answer
whether we are okay that russians are
doing that that they are literally
blockading odessa that they are not
allowing a safe passage for the ships to
leave to leave ukrainian ports and and
reach turkey and other countries that
that require the food
so i think that
there has been already a debate but i
think a time
is coming where we need to find
solutions
because other other ways you know
bringing food out of ukraine via
trains and and trucks and all that it is
it is possible to do that but not in the
amounts that ukrainians actually can
provide to the world so you feel that
the um blockade of odessa is a tipping
point in this war perhaps
well at least if we might even see that
as a parallel thing a parallel uh track
that is happening while the war is
waging you know we've talked about the
war that it has to be won on ukrainian
terms but then the world needs its food
obviously and knowing that ukraine was a
major provider of food
and we have to really look into the ways
how to how to help ukrainians to to
really to do that safely and again on
their terms what do you make of the fact
that a couple of countries are trying to
stop finland and sweden becoming nato
members i'm talking about turkey and
croatia
well first of all i'm not
um
particularly worried that it will be the
full stop i think that you know there
has to be a conversation i know that the
conversation is taking place between
helsinki's tahoe and ankur
and i hope that they will bear fruit uh
in the diplomatic manner that you know
the decisions will will be found because
otherwise that will spell a you know
kind of a gloomy future for for for an
alliance if we in the times of crisis if
we're unable to make
a certain strategic steps that are so
much so much needed for for the alliance
the second step apart from
finland and sweden joining nato is the
defense of eastern flank
where you know when lithuania is very
much interested because as you as you
know russia's troops are so close now to
our borders they haven't been there
before the 24th of february but you're a
member of nato we are a member of nato
but we would like to see the alliance
stepping up with their defense on the on
the eastern flank so apart from the two
two of our neighbors i could say
neighbors in the region joining nato i
think that we need to see more allied
troops in the nato territory on the
eastern flank especially in the baltics
what do you want to hear before i let
you go from the foreign secretary our
foreign secretary today what would you
consider to be a successful meeting
well we had a number of meetings before
and so basically i would uh i would
expect a coordination about uh the
further steps
you know we we're so close to where the
war is going on and uh we have some
ideas we have some proposals but we need
we need our allies to join in on on that
and uh it has been successful in the
past and we're truly hoping that we can
continue on that track are you concerned
about russia
absolutely
russia has proven that it's an
aggressive
actor aggressive country
ready to use force against its neighbors
and i don't think
that it
is about to change while the regime is
in power good to talk to you